we're gonna go gambling we're creating a
let's call it a fictional casino
and we're playing a game with a 50 50
chance of winning okay
so we're doing roulette red or black so
there's no zero so it is
actually a 50 50 chance red or black
what we're going to look at is something
called the martingale strategy
every time you lose a bet you double
down
on the next bet and therefore eventually
you will
win is the idea what do you mean by
double down
so if you bet one pound and lose then
you bet again
and you would bet two pounds and then if
you lost again then you go four pounds
if you lose you go eight pounds so you
double the last bet you made
provided you have pretty much unlimited
money you will eventually
win a win is come out of our fictional
casino with more money than i went in do
you want to make a profit exactly we're
making a profit should we say we're
always betting on red
or black or what do you think i i'm
tempted to go black i'm sorry
so i write with a black pen i think if i
was given the choice i would i would i'd
like a
i'm going for black over red i think
okay so we're betting on black bedding
on black and we're going to keep going
you think about well when is the first
time i lose so if i lose at step k
i've had my bet at step one
and i bet one pound and then i must have
lost
because we're assuming we're going to
keep going until this number k then at
step
two i bet two pounds then step three
again we're assuming i've lost at step
two i double my bet
so this is now going to be four pounds
step
four is going to be double that eight
pounds and this
carries on if you win your money gets
doubled if i win my money will be
doubled yes it's a 50 50 game
such that whatever i bet like in exactly
like roulette we don't have a zero
but the rules otherwise are the same if
i bet on black which is what we're doing
if it lands on black i double my money
because that zero is how casino is in
sure
zero exactly you know this way the zero
is how casinos know this and this is why
they have zero because it's never a 50
50 chance
but our mathematically fair casino gives
us a true 50 50 chance at step
k then we can figure out how much we
would be
betting because there's a pattern here
so at step one
i bet one pounds step two two pounds
step three four pounds
so what's happening with our bets is
these are increasing powers of two
so this is times two times two times two
so the actual formula
is going to be two to the power of k
minus one so we can just check this so
at step one so k is one two to the power
of zero is one
step two k is two two to the power one
is two
two squared is four two cubed is eight
so
step k we have just bet
2 to the k minus 1 pounds
if i then lose at step k my total loss
so far is the sum of all of these bets
so 1 plus 2
plus 4 plus eight all the way up to two
to the k minus one we can write this as
the sum from
j equals naught k minus one of two
power j so two to the naught is one then
plus
two to the one is two plus 2 squared is
4. so this is a shorthand way of writing
out this sum
and this is what we call a geometric
series we
have a formula for the sum of a
geometric series so
we can plug it in it's the first term
which is
1. multiplied by one minus
the next term in the sequence so it ends
at two to the k minus one
so if we were to go to the next step
that would be two to the k
and then we divide by one minus
the common ratio between the terms
so what we're multiplying by at each
step so divided by one minus two so you
tidy this up
and this is two to the k minus
1. so this is the total amount of money
i have lost when i lose my bet at step
k so in the next step i'm going to bet
2 to the k pounds i'm going to win
hopefully
and then that covers my losses with one
pound to spare
so after all of this effort after losing
at some step
if i follow the martingale strategy i
will eventually win
we hope before i run out of money that's
a whole other question
and i will win one pound so we're not
exactly
like it's good it's a profit but it's
it's not like we want more than a pound
don't we really like you don't really go
to a casino to make a pout
but if you scaled up to 10 pounds or a
million pounds as
as you're as you're like you're multiple
you you're guaranteed to win a million
pounds
yeah so so to win a million pounds
you've got to
go through this strategy one million
times winning one pound each time
or just make that a million pound bet
a two million pound bet a four million
pounds all the way to a two
to the minus one times a million we
could also do that yet so we could also
change
the amount we bet at the beginning and
then that would be
the amount that you your initial stake
is the amount that you'll win
through this strategy so this strategy
is going to win you
through this process we're going to win
a pound each time now
there are problems with this there is a
reason that this is not a foolproof
gambling strategy first of all
most games aren't 50 50. if we're doing
roulette there's a zero which is green
so it's not red or black so you're not
actually got a 50 50 chance
and that kind of really alters what's
what's happening in some casinos there
were two zeros this is
yes zero and double zero exactly yeah so
they're even they're even
are those odds the other thing is
casinos have maximum bet limits
in most casinos you can't walk in and
just drop a million pounds
like they're gonna be like no there's a
maximum bet limit here
and even if you start really low and you
keep losing
this will grow really quickly this is
exponential growth which
we know a lot about these days and this
will grow really quickly
and it will actually reach a million a
lot faster than you realize so if red
comes up
lots of times in a row yeah you're going
to reach the maximum betting limit in an
actual casino and then
you're screwed you've then lost like a
million pounds you've not got a chance
to get your money back
because that's the key if this fails
you've lost
2 to the power k minus 1 pounds which is
a lot of money if
k is like 10 or something like so it can
really really ramp up
just for the sake of clarity too tom i
would imagine
it doesn't really matter what you're
placing the bits on red or black
like you don't really have to be betting
on the color you lost on no no no
exactly
every time because it's an equal chance
of each one coming up
you you can switch you could maybe go
red black red black red it doesn't
matter because the probability will
always be a half
yeah and and it will always be the same
so you don't have to bet on what you're
lost on you just have no you have to bet
again just have to bet again yes exactly
you can bet on anything
um in the 50 50 situation
[Applause]
another issue nobody in the world has a
limited body it might feel like some
people do but there is a number
where the maximum amount any individual
could bet
that's our bank balance n pounds if at
any point
we need to bet more money than we
have we're screwed and not only can we
not win on one pounds
we've literally lost everything that we
own
so we really don't want this to happen
does your previous winnings
become part of that pot you can dig into
no so so the the 100 pound limit here
is the um like that's my pot so even if
i start to win
maybe i've won 50 in a row and now i in
theory have 150
but what we're saying here is that 50
i've won that that's in a separate pot
that seemed like a
that's in your money box that goes in
the bank you cannot touch that
we've said here that we're losing at
step k and in the next step
we would have to bet 2 to the power k so
if i have to bet 2 to the k pounds
if this is ever bigger than my
n pounds game over
sad face you're bankrupt that's it we
all cry so
we can't have this happen now what you
can figure out is
how does this tell you about k
because k remember is the number of
losses that were allowed so we can start
to plug some numbers in here and think
about well if i go in with 100 pounds
how many losses am i allowed before i
lost all my hundred quid you just
rearrange this slightly so we can say
2 to the k is equal to n just to make
things a bit easier so obviously if we
go a little bit above this
then we fail so let's look at the
boundary case of when they're equal
so then you take log to the base two of
both sides
and what that does is tell you this
to be our value of k now this is quite
hard to interpret because we don't
really have any numbers
so let's put some numbers in so if i
come in with n
being 100 pounds so we start with 100
pounds
you're allowed seven losses it's not too
bad but it might seem unlikely
well i'm not gonna lose seven times in a
row you would be amazed how common it is
to lose seven times in a row like
there's
loads of really nice studies done on
this at how bad
we are as humans at thinking oh i'll
never be that unlucky
it's really easy to lose seven times
seven reds in a row and you're you're
out if we're betting black yeah and then
if you went up to say a thousand pounds
then you will get about 10 losses so
even though you've
ten times your initial stake you only
get an extra three losses
and this kind of pattern continues it
starts to come down so if you had 10 000
pounds
then you've got 14 losses and if you
even went all the way up to brady's idea
of a million pounds
you've got 20 losses you get twice as
many losses from 10 to 20 going from a
thousand to a million pounds no matter
how much your money goes up this starts
to slow down quite drastically
and still this is only going to win you
one pound this is to still win one pound
yeah this is just to win one pass we
have this
relationship then between the number of
losses and the money that we've put in
so what we can do then is say right well
it's a 50 50 game
so what is the probability that i
lose k times in a row well if i lose
once
that's a half then if i lose again
that's a half
these are independent events it doesn't
matter what happened in the previous
one so it's literally just a half to the
power k so if i've lost
k times it's a half to the power k this
is actually
1 over 2 to the k and we have this
relationship up here
between 2 to the k and the amount of
money we start with n
so the probability that i lose k times
in a row and lose
all of my money and all of my belongings
is one divided by
the amount of money i have in the first
place so perhaps as expected
the richer i am the less likely it is
that i lose all of my money and we have
this really nice probability given in
terms of the amount of money we start
with
so if this is the probability that i
lose
k times in a row and lose all of my
fortune
then the probability that i win
which here is winning one pounds is one
minus this
because the total probability has to
always be one so the probability
that i win one pound using this strategy
is one minus one over n and as n
increases this number goes really small
so the probability is really close to
one
if you tom walk into the casino with a
hundred pounds in your back pocket which
i think is conceivable okay yeah let's
go with that
and you play this strategy yeah how
likely is it you're gonna walk out with
your one pound profit
so if i put in for n equals 100
then the probability i win one pounds is
going to be
uh one minus one over 100 so that's
going to be 99 out of 100. so there's a
99
chance that i win a pound but this is
the key thing
there's a one percent chance really
small but then i lose 100 quid
i really don't want to lose 100 quid to
have even because i'm only doing it to
win a pound
is it worth so it's only a one percent
chance yes but is it worth that one
percent chance that i lose my hundred
quid
just to win a pound if we do this
properly i want to double
the money i start with so we need to win
one pound 100 times in a row so we need
to go through this whole strategy
with our probability of 1 minus 1 over n
but we need to do it
100 times in a row and so
i'm going to need more paper the
probability of winning one pound
is 1 minus 1 over n so the probability
of winning
100 times in a row which means winning
100 pounds is just
well i need to win the first one then i
need to win the second one
so that's just multiply the probability
together then i win the third so it's
actually just this
to the power of a hundred if i wanted to
win 100 times in a row it's this
probability
to a higher and higher power we're using
the example here of me and my hundred
pounds
if i just wanted the probability of
doubling my money
for any n then it's going to just be one
minus one over n
each time i win one pound i've got to
win n times so it's one minus one over n
to the power n
what is going on here so let's put in
some numbers if n is a hundred
we plug this into our formula so it's
gonna be one minus one over 100
to the power 100 and that comes out to
be
0.366 so if we put that as a percent
it's going to be 36.6 so a little bit
over a third
chance of me going in with my 100 pounds
and doubling my money through this
martingale
doubling strategy so this is a long
night this is a very long night yeah
because that's
i really got to win 100 times in a row
so i have to employ this
strategy 100 times the and
and hope that none of them
i have a long if i ever get a long
enough losing streak to run out of money
that's it i've lost 100 pounds
right so i really do need to go back and
redo the same thing 100 times
but if i do that i then got 36.6
chance of doubling my money through this
strategy i suppose i'm a little bit more
of a high roller and
i go for a thousand pounds the value is
0.368
so if i have a little bit more money i
get an increase
0.2 percent still starting with one
dollar bet so i can never bet anything
more than a thousand
that's like all i've had to put forward
into this situation and then if i was to
really go big
and start and say well you know what
i've got a million pounds of capital
i wish um then the value here
is also 0.368. 36.8
so something's happening this is this is
as a mathematician this is where you get
your joy
you sort of you start thinking about
these fictional casinos these
probability problems
and then you start to spot patterns what
the hell's going on
what we're really doing here as n is
increasing
is you've got like a contest between
these two numbers
because as n gets bigger and bigger this
value in the bracket gets closer to one
because you're taking away a smaller
smaller number but as
n gets bigger you're taking a number
less than one
to a larger and larger power and when
you have numbers less than one
to any power so say a half squared it
gets smaller
so any number less than one raised to
any power
positive whole number power is going to
get smaller and smaller
so this is always less than one and
we're raising it to a bigger bigger
power
so it's there's like a competition
because you're taking away smaller
pieces
but you're multiplying it by itself more
and more times and that's why you get
this limit it's an actual limiting
process the two balance out and
eventually reach this constant and the
constant
and this is my favorite bit about this
whole problem if you take
n to infinity and do a proper limiting
process on 1 minus 1 over n
to the n this is 1 over
e euler's number the natural rate of
growth
the number tattooed on my arm
it's it appears everywhere right
anything you're doing
with growth it seems anything with
interest gambling money it's always e
so here it's one ovary so the big
conclusion
is if i have a fixed amount of money
n pounds i'm willing to try and double
using the martingale strategy no matter
how much money i have
the absolute best chance i have of
doubling my money
is about 37 or 1 over e and there's
nothing i can do about that if i get
more and more money
i i still have the same chance 36.8
chance of winning in this method so
some of you may have spotted this
earlier i may realize what's going on
here
and you have to think well we're playing
a 50 50 game
like we're literally playing roulette
red or black so we can go through all of
this
and have you know the world's longest
stint in casino trying to double a
million pounds
and do a million iterations of the
martingale strategy
but i'm never going to get more than a
36.8 chance of doubling my money
so why don't i just put everything on
black on the first spin
because then i've got a 50 chance of
actually
doubling my money so the moral of the
story i think is
gambling strategies are all good and fun
but
they're always gonna break down for many
reasons
one of which is you don't have an
infinite amount of money so even though
we can in theory win one pound every
time
if you let time be long enough you're
never actually going to
to double your money or your your
expected value really does shrink to
zero
so the martingale strategy in theory
looks great
if you do it with sensible numbers
saying i want to double my money
literally you're better off just putting
it all on black and hoping for the best
if you'd like to see even more number
five videos with tom crawford
well we've got a playlist there's a link
on the screen and down in the video
description
because there's more competition to eat
those rabbits also tom will be appearing
very soon on the numberphile podcast so
keep an ear out for that
thank you also to numberphile's patreon
supporters
we have a list of the whole list of
supporters i'll include a link to that
in the video description but a few of
them are also listed here on the screen
you can see their names at the moment
special thanks to them if you'd like to
help us out go to patreon.com
numberfire we really appreciate it
but we also appreciate everyone who just
takes the time to watch and like and
share these videos
and that includes you yes you i'm
talking to you specifically
you